Understanding how Unreal Engine 5 projects are structured is very important as Unreal
Engine 5 projects are set up in a slightly different way than you might be used to in
traditional applications.
This is because in a traditional application, you generally use a single project file to
visualize your scene.
So when we're inside a Photoshop and we save, we're going to save it to a .psd.
Or inside of Word when we save, we're going to save to the .doc or the same for Maya if
we save, we're going to save to the .mb format.
Now Unreal has a slightly different approach to this.
When you're inside of Unreal Engine 5 and you want to import something such as a model,
a texture, audio, or animations, all of that is going to be stored in the content folder
and use a .usset file format.
There are two other file formats that we should be aware of.
The first one is the level file format.
This is called the .umap file format.
And this is for any levels that we happen to be saving.
And levels is a term for what we place actors or our content and we light and it's what
the end user ends up seeing in your project.
Now if we are creating, say, a material or editing an asset inside of Unreal, whatever
we're doing inside of there is going to be saved again in the .usset file format.
Again, if we are importing something such as a static mesh or maybe a texture, whatever
we export will be done is, say, a .fbx or a .png.
And when we bring that into Unreal, that's going to be imported and then saved as this
.usset file format.
Now here is an example of an Unreal Engine project folder.
And you'll notice quite a few different folders in here, but don't worry.
A lot of these folders are actually auto-generated and can be deleted in case you need to either
share your project with someone else or you run into an issue and you kind of want to
start fresh.
We can actually do that.
So let's go ahead and take a look at what these folders are now.
So right down here we have our .uproject.
This is going to associate Unreal Engine to run.
When we click on this, it's going to say, hey, I want you to load Unreal Engine, but I want
you to load the Engine and all of the content that is created inside of this folder right
here.
Now above that we have the Valley of the Ancients.png.
This is our thumbnail that represents what we'll see inside of the Unreal Engine launcher
that's associated with our project.
Then we have Source.
So this is going to contain any of our C++ code that we might run custom for this particular
project.
And this is a file that you need to keep, so never delete your source.
Now saved contains saved information and this can be a whole bunch of different things.
One of the things that you'll find in here are, say, screenshots.
You'll also find crash dumps.
You'll find build data.
One of the things you can do with saved is you can actually delete this folder should
you ever need to just maybe free up some space or something like that.
This is a saved folder to delete.
It will automatically be recreated once your project has been relaunched.
Now your plugins folder contains any plugins that you might have either purchased or created
specifically for this particular project or maybe there are plugins that you have set
up so that you can share content in between your projects.
The plugins folder is not safe to delete as doing so could actually reduce functionality
that your project needs.
So you need to keep that folder at all times.
Your intermediates folder is where things like shader compilation data builds, partially
completed compilations and other things like that are stored.
It's a bunch of just miscellaneous data in here.
This folder can be safely deleted should you be running into any issues as it will automatically
be recreated once the engine has been relaunched.
Your derived data cache is a folder that contains pre-compiled versions of your shaders and this
allows the engine to run much, much quicker.
I shouldn't say run.
I apologize.
It allows it to load much, much quicker.
You can delete your derived data cache but I suggest that you don't as this will greatly
affect your loading times.
Next is our content.
So the content is where all of our content are .usets and our .umaps files live.
We always need to keep the content folder that's not safe to delete that folder or you'll
be deleting all of the content for your project.
Next we have our config.
The config is where we store all of our config information and this will control how the
editor starts or what settings are used when the game is loaded.
You should not be deleting the config folder as you need that information for when the
editor starts or when your game launches.
Next we have our build.
This is where we are going to temporarily store builds that we have done for our project
that is safe to delete your builds folder.
This folder can actually grow quite large so if your project is all of a sudden taking
up too much space you might want to delete this folder.
It will be recreated when Unreal Engine restarts.
And then last but not least we have our binaries.
This is going to be created should you have any binaries that you want to have for your
project.
If you don't see this folder that's okay.
I believe it was created after the fact but you can delete this folder without any issues.
Now if we dive into one of these folders we're going to look at something like this.
Here we are looking at the attenuation and this is basically notice that there are all
UAsset files here.
We're just looking at one folder here.
While I am visualizing this inside of Windows Explorer one thing I want to note is that
you should never mess with files outside of Unreal.
Let's say we did want to take all of these attenuation files and maybe make a new folder
and split half of them or some other organizational thing that we want to do.
We should never ever ever do that outside of Unreal Engine 5.
We should always do that inside of the editor using the editor renaming and moving functionalities
that are provided in there.
Now with all of these great files and everything there can be some bottlenecks.
Traditionally in older versions of Unreal whenever you wanted to make a change to anything
you would need to make that change inside of our UMAP.
Now the problem with this is that the UMAP folder was or should say the UMAP file is
unique and only one person can have it checked out at one time.
This means that whenever I want to make a change to it I either have to wait for somebody
else to finish making their changes or come up with a complex way to work on my stuff
and then somehow merge it with theirs later on.
This can create a lot of conflicts especially as teams start to grow in size.
With Unreal Engine 5 we've introduced a new file system called one file per actor which
reduces overlaps between users and does this by saving data for instance the vectors in
external files and this actually removes the need to save everything to the UMAP file.
So instead of everything being saved to the UMAP file it's now linked to the UMAP file
and this will allow multiple people to be working in the same world all adding and adjusting
things without worrying about whether or not somebody has something checked in or checked
out.
Now just a couple of things to note about one file per actor.
It is recommended that you do use Unreal Engine 5 source control when you enable this because
it is going to involve a lot more files than you might be used to because remember we're
going to be making a file for pretty much everything that you see that's placed inside
of the level.
With that said you should also be utilizing the built in editor check in and check out
tools to help check your data in, check your data out and last but not least remember that
using one file per actor is meant to work in tandem with world partition so using it
outside of this system might result in some unintended uses or unforeseen edge cases so
just be on the lookout for that.